[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in from the
Museum of Curiosities it feels like it's
been forever since we've had a chance to
connect by now you know the drill after
every season we open up the phone lines
for your hard-hitting end of season fan
questions and boy did you guys deliver
this year from the YouTube from the
Facebook from the Instagram you guys
gave us your season 17 questions and now
right now it's time to answer them put
my feet to the fire put me in the hot
seat for once and we're just a Dom slide
of the bucket away from kicking this
thing off
On Cue look at that diving in to the
bucket of questions and we begin with
jonay murocheski curious to what or who
motivates you on a daily basis do you
have a North star or are you more of a
self-motivated individual
so the number one principal motivating
factor in my life is a fear of
humiliation and then the other thing
that motivates me is respect for
people's time and when I say people's
time I mean respect for our guest time
and respect for our audience's time so
between those three things you know you
you want to make sure that you make the
most of your time with the guest if they
agree to sit down and eat scorching hot
chicken wings with you you should meet
them halfway on what's hopefully a
thoughtful and considered interview and
then for the audience this time you know
you go through all that and then you
hope you can deliver on a product that's
worth watching so between those things
those three things together that is all
the battery pack in my back that I need
to stay motivated so very good question
and that's the answer all right up next
from Michael kenniston do you have
alternate questions you can ask based on
how the celebrity is handling the sauces
so I really like this question and yes
there's quite a bit of uh sort of lever
pulling there are some audibles that are
called in-game action all the time so if
a guest is is really struggling with the
sauces and struggling to connect and
focus through the interview then you
might switch to asking more direct
questions with less elaborate context
you know what I mean just kind of
simplify things as they're just hanging
on by a thread but then the other side
of that is sometimes you can crank
things up so if a guest is really
leaning into the interview is really
engaged you can tell that they're being
very generous in the interview then you
might Crank It Up a few notches the Matt
Damon episode for example when we had
him put his Mount Rushmore of movies
that he's been in you know that was we
had another Wing 10 question there but
he was leaning so much into the
interview that I'm like maybe we can
take this shot right here or having
Justin Timberlake rank his albums that
was another one where we had a different
wingten and then you're like this is
going really well oh they're leaning
into this I think that we can take this
swing which brings up another point
which is like the wing 10 sometimes
naturally they turn into this sort of
post-mortem on the experience as a whole
Dave Grohl in this season for example
also Josh Brolin in this wing for
example so when the experience is kind
of put it's encapsulated in this nice
pretty package then you won't just like
all right well this was so lovely let's
stop pause change the energy I now have
a question that I want to ask you here
comes your answer you know if Russell
Brand just busts out in song then you
just end on a high note this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life good
question
all right up next
if Sean could be interviewed by anybody
who would he choose off the top of my
head I'm not exactly sure who I'd choose
to interview me all the time but there's
some new shows that have been popping up
in the space uh that have really
impressed me uh with the way that
they're done the the concepts the
personalities involved uh so if I could
just shout some people out
um Andrew Callahan all gas no breaks
formerly not Channel 5 News doing
amazing work chicken shop date shout out
to my girl Amelia I love that show Caleb
Presley with like the Sunday
conversations on these field pieces that
he's doing also awesome and then uh
Speedy my boy Speedy Mormon having
himself a great couple years here and
then uh you know it was highly
underrated as a podcast host an
interviewer is Pete Holmes like when I
was at Pete Holmes podcast I'm always
like wow that was like an amazing
interview every time I listened to one
people don't talk about Pete Holmes
enough as being like one of the great
interviewers of our time but shout out
to Pete Holmes thank you for the
question just wanted to shout those
people out all right up now
let's play 17 years for the Baltimore
Ravens you know like what I do there's
obviously a physical toll to it but is
it more physically harmful is it more
dangerous than playing 17 years in the
NFL playing linebacker at a high level
I don't think so you know or at least
I'll take my chances like if Ray Lewis
can put together 17 seasons in the NFL
certainly I should be able to eat
scorching out chicken wings once a week
for like I don't know 10 years or 11 or
12 or 15 or maybe I can hit that 17 Mark
so I don't really know how long I'll
last you know I do keep an eye on it I
do hit the doctor but everything's going
good and I do love everything about what
I'm doing right now and I love the show
and I love the people I make the show
with and I can't imagine what my life
would be like without it at this point
so you know as long as I hold up and as
long as people care then I think I've
got some more years of doing this and at
least I hope I have more years of doing
this and like I said Ray Lewis if you
can play 17 years in the NFL like why
can't I do 10 or 15 or 17 hosting hot
ones that's the way I look at it am I a
[ __ ] maybe all right up next from germ
wait hold on hold on all right they seem
to want me
to go in for the truth or dab game
and ask answer a question out of the
truth or dab game so here we go
all right
truth or dab I don't see any Wings here
so I guess I'll be forced into truth
what's the best prank you've ever pulled
off
all right I do actually have a I
actually have a decent prank so one time
I had a buddy who's getting married and
it was like a very high stress lots of
moving Parts kind of wedding that they
were gonna put together so we were like
let's prank phone call our friend so
what we did is we downloaded an app that
would allow you to change your number
and then we had the voice changing thing
on it so I changed my voice to a girl's
voice changed the number to where they
were having their rehearsal dinner at
this place called The Carriage House and
the concept for the prank phone call was
I was gonna pretend like I was calling
from the carriage house and that they
double booked the carriage house so I
called this guy up I'm like oh you know
like I have really bad news we've
actually double booked your rehearsal
dinner like he no longer has a venue and
then basically I had a series of sort of
plan B's little ways that I could kind
of uh take care of this problem but none
of them would work like I was like well
we have this room called The chestnut
room unfortunately it's a dry room and
we can only serve uh you know soda and
iced tea and water does that work and
then this dummy he would cover up the
phone and be like hey babe
so they have a dry room where they can
only do soda iced tea and water and then
just hear her just Tasmanian Devil going
nuts that's when he like snaps back in
like no that won't work and then I'm
like okay well we also have another room
it's the Coach House room uh
unfortunately there will only see 60
people so like 40 of your guests are
gonna have to eat in the hallway or
outside then you'd be like okay cool hey
babe so they have this other room the
Coach House room but it only seats 60 so
we'll have to come up with a list of
like 40 people that have to eat outside
and then she's like going nuts and then
that's when he like starts to put his
foot down and he's like yelling at me
like how can you do this this is so
unprofessional we're two weeks away all
of this stuff and then I just said to
him wow dude I'm really bending over
backwards for you not sure why you're
being such a butthole and then I held
the phone up like this it was on speaker
I had like four friends around me and he
just goes
did you and very indignant did you just
call me a butthole
and the whole room exploded top five
hardest I've ever laughed in my life so
there's a little prank story for you off
the top of my head
all right we're almost to the bottom of
the bucket here
let's see
germ we gotta pick up with germ what was
the inspiration for the voice you used
to make fun of fans that dumb questions
or complaints I find it very enjoyable
when you rip into people like that
alright so
so it started uh because it's just like
how when back when I used to read Reddit
comments like the Reddit comments in my
internal like the internal voice in my
head sounded like that you know it's
just like the way they talk kind of like
am I the only one who's disappointed in
the fact that right like it's like got a
certain like a certain like thing to it
I don't know it's like a certain
curmudgeonly or emotional like thing
there's a certain note that is like very
specific to Reddit comments so when I'd
read the comments back to Chris I would
read them in that voice so that's kind
of where it came from and then it's
stuck and then I think the reason it
connects is because like everybody kind
of sees that but
shout out to Reddit uh big part of why
this show blew up in the first place
shout out to the hot one subreddit shout
out to the hot one subreddit uh no
disrespect
all in good fun
you guys do kind of sound like that
though sometimes
action that you like to promote when you
were working as a copywriter for the
Chicago tourism board all right so in
addition to actually doing that I I was
also a tour guide on the Chicago River
shout out to Chicago's first lady and
the Chicago architecture foundation so
that was a tour that I did
for like six years like all the way
through college and everything I would
just be on the river just delivering
tours so if you'd like real quick here
are my uh here's my Mount Rushmore of
Chicago buildings on the architecture
Tour all right I like the Civic Opera
building 333 Wacker cone Patterson and
fox love the contextualism love the
backstory I also love Tribune Tower I
love the Wrigley building I'll kind of
connect those because they're right
across the street from each other
they're on whacker and the leopornet
building those are I think I listed five
but my Mount Rushmore buildings on an
architectural level that I used to love
seeing every day and talking about on
the architecture tour and uh shout out
to Chicago as well there we go Nathan
Potts asks what are your feelings after
a heartwarming episode especially end
credits scene with Dave Grohl I actually
did stay that week I I went to the
premiere got to go to the Foo Fighters
concert the next night there was a
moment that uh Dave actually took the
mic and then he goes uh he goes between
songs he goes last night I got to do my
favorite show of all time and woke up at
one o'clock in the morning with a rumble
in my stomach and [ __ ] my [ __ ] brains
out and then the whole crowd went crazy
and then he goes so this next song is
dedicated to Sean from hot ones then he
did shame we're like during the course
he'd be like shame shame on you Sean
shame on you Sean and then the whole
crowd was going shame on you Sean shame
on you Sean so it's an unforgettable
experience the shoot one of the most
memorable of my life uh Dave's such a
Soulful guy instant connection
everything about it uh is amazing to me
personally is it felt like like for you
watching it the way it translated on and
off camera was absolutely amazing and a
treasure and rest in peace to Taylor
Hawkins shout out to the Foo Fighters
shout out to Dave uh amazing
life-changing shifting uh moment for the
show and for me personally so can't get
better than that
well there it is the
we are almost ready to roll curtains but
before we do that we need to check in on
camera guy Bill camera guy Bill he's
always staying busy during the off
season it is time to check back in with
him Bill what is going on in your world
[Music]
oh hey there Sean I've got big build
plans for this off season as you know
I've been working on my Mixology skills
and I've decided to level it up a bit
this time and that's why I brought in
spicy cocktail expert Rico from absolute
to show me how to make a drink that'll
bring the heat into next season Rico
thank you for being here Bill thank you
for having me here very excited I'm very
excited to have you here shall we make
some drinks let's do it this is the hot
ass [ __ ] michelada well that sounds
absolute Lee terrifying
where's the inspiration for this drink
come from not from your dad jokes
inspiration just comes from the show
okay should we get into making this
drink then let's do it you're gonna make
one alongside me okay you're not just
standing around okay I'm ready okay so
let's take a little play and what we've
got is some salt some fresh ground
Szechuan peppers and then we can go
straight in to just decorating
you'll see that you get some on the
inside yeah so if you want to get rid of
that you can just
science and then you just got that nice
little Rim across the top
so the glasses are prepped now we can
start to like build the drink so we're
going to start one ounce of lime juice
I'm gonna put that in straight like that
oh Splash Zone I'm known as spill King
on my shirt so that's fine that's
happening it's okay next up we want to
take absolute original vodka gotcha and
we want equal parts to what the lime
juice is so stick it out in one ounce
nice
look at that next up
it's the real one it's the last dab so
let's take a bottle each you gotta do
the Shawn Shake yeah shake Sean shake
this is the Sean Shake moment okay so
we want to go oh man two drops two drops
two drops that's a drop
and now we want to shake this okay so we
want to get some ice
you want to get as much ice as possible
into the Shaker give it a good shape
nice I got it that's good so now what we
want to do we want to ice up our glasses
so I just pour just go in
you can see how much more last up I got
in there
so next up we want to get a nice light
here
give it a little second to rest and
that's it there you have it that's the
hottest [ __ ] michelada well all I know
is these look great and I know I'm gonna
drink a michelada these oh come on over
break see what I did there
check out absolute drinks with Rico on
YouTube for more excellent drink
Creations Rico thank you for being here
thank you cheers to you cheers bro
cheers of the spice Lords she has two
spice Lords and Sean I think you're
gonna want to try one of these
well cheers to you Bill and cheers to
you watching this thank you so much for
rocking with us now through 17 seasons
and cheers to season 18. we'll see you
soon
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans and they said we were
crazy they said we were nuts a hot sauce
for kids they said it wouldn't it
shouldn't be done well guess what we did
it anyway and now we're doubling down we
started with the green say hello to hot
ones Junior the yellow
the yellow is a super mild hot sauce
with sweet tropical heat from mango
pineapple and Scotch bonnet pepper
whether you're a parent child or just
want a super mild sauce this is the
sauce for you and if you want to be the
first person to try it the April hot one
subscription box is where you'll find it
sign up by April 15th heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to sign up and
Order
the yellow